so i started grabbing like a big bag of
m m's and stuff
and i started throwing candies and
marshmallows and m m's and
[ __ ] they must have loved all this so
so they're going yeah they're all
[ __ ] cheering
and then the lady comes in she taps me
and she gives me a piece of paper
[ __ ] 350 dollars a [ __ ]
[ __ ] candy i threw up there
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to
oh my god hi
with me george lopez
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere
what's his name george
[Music]
if you're feeling overwhelmed lately
you're not alone so start feeling better
with a single message talk space online
therapy matches you with a license
therapist
from the comfort of your device get 100
off right now your first month
with the code omg hi
at talkspace.com good luck
the olympics euros baseball major
champions and concerts
all in the same summer and you know what
isn't in fashion
are wild and hairy bush okay hey tame
your pubes with the help of friends at
manscape the leaders in below
the waist grooming i got mine arsenio
hall got his brother like that i said
his name but he got his
the fourth generation performance
package includes the brand new lawnmower
4.0
if an athlete treats their body like
royalty
why not treat your pubes like you're
staying on the podium with a gold medal
around your neck
fellas do right by your balls and join
two million men
i wasn't going to be in a gang but i'd
be in this one worldwide
who trust manscaped get 20 of our free
shipping with the code
omg hi manscape.com
this is a cultural thing too so i'm
telling you
make it right down there all right let
me tell you
hey make it right with the man
downstairs
oh my god hot is brought to you by green
chef so green chef is the most
sustainable meal kid
it's fun it's easy and you can try
helping your recipes at home with
green chef try green chef today the
number one meal kit
for eating well and you know you don't
have to get home
and just put meals together green chef
puts them together for you so go to
greenchef.com
hi 100 and use the code omg
hi 100 to get 100 off including
free shipping all right get green chef
and then let me see what you look like
absolutely looking good
and which one of you guys brought the
[ __ ] sword oh well aaron did who
brought the sword
you know sometimes when you get like a
souvenir sword it weighs like it's
nothing
that [ __ ] thing was 150 pounds this
is like a movie like the real
[ __ ] replica of lord of the rings
i think is no [ __ ] joke that's
everything yeah 14 pounds were they
stronger back then
that's a little baby i shall destroy you
yeah
it was funny too because they signed the
sword and they they signed it like you
know billy boy john mcmahon and then
they signed their character names next
to it too just because you know
so many people are like either well who
is that or which one were you
right yeah whatever and they just stayed
they figured it out you recognized it
your nickname so so explain to me that
you know now that we have now that
they're not here in front of me
are they are those two guys recognizable
all over the world
uh definitely not
yeah and they have one story too where
and maybe they probably know them as
like the hobbits but don't know who they
are but i forget where they said they
were but they were like bora bora or
some [ __ ]
and there's someone local came up to
them and they were like mary
what are you guys doing prosthetics like
to do that star trek that the michael
dorn that guy had that
full-on like yeah yeah like the ripples
in his
door which is which years ago was that
dwarf warfare is the character mike
cheers guys
yeah it's bad luck but i guess i'm on
the clock you're working or something
yes
were you a cop legally i don't have to
tell you
is it happy that's delicious man i
really like it so so the um
yeah so they're known all around the
world right yeah oh yeah but they don't
have anything on their face or anything
either
they're just made just tiny are they
actually tiny in person
no they're i mean they're normal size no
they're not they're a little bit smaller
they're not hobbit-sized they are
they're a little on the shoulder for
adults but it is it is funny because in
my head i'm like you're supposed to be
like up to here you know what was crazy
about
about halloween is that when we like i'm
considerably i'm twice your guys age
but in our day every candy was like a
full-sized candy
like you couldn't buy fun-sized candy
right yeah like if you
have groceries long yeah bars every
anything you'd get
just normal size right and then
somewhere along the line somebody at
mars probably said hey
you can just probably sell like smaller
ones that will sell more of them than
selling a big one right yeah and there
you go the fun size but
you wouldn't even
but then it changed everything because
if you went trick-or-treating and you
didn't even get to a lot of houses
your bag was heavy because everything
was a normal size right
thing so they try to get penny sometimes
yeah
and nowadays you just try and map out
which house in the neighborhood does
give the actual size
candy bars and you get all them but but
i think that
i think that it could be i mean it's a
blessing to be a working actor but i
think that if you're in a show
like or or part of a franchise like that
that it does get to be
oh you can't have your identity anymore
man you can't go yeah
and because that's who you are and
because that's such a big
it's big all over the world like anybody
would see you
they would go up to you because they
feel like they can go up to you now
right
when and back in the day maybe 15 years
ago yeah
you wouldn't you wouldn't go up to
somebody if they were eating and if you
did they would say
you know i'm eating and now they're
starting to tape
or or video you even before they get
near you so if you say i'm eating
they'll say that [ __ ] [ __ ] i go
yeah he's eating he's trying to eat
there's nobody's nobody's uh you know i
was with uh let me drop a name i was uh
i was with clint eastwood having dinner
with his wife and my wife
and don johnson walked up and he goes
hey claire how are you doing bubba
and he goes hey man you know because
clint you know
don's like hey i gotta probably
shouldn't use his real name
all right he said he goes hey hey bubba
i gotta get your number mac clint's
sitting there and he goes
i'm more of a transmitter than a
receiver
oh okay all right well have you noticed
anything like that do you feel extra
pressure in like the you know the social
media area at any point in time
someone's going to come up to you maybe
they'll be recording oh wait a minute
you mean when i
fell asleep in that [ __ ] casino drunk
after like 21 shots of tequila and
somebody took a picture and ended up on
tmz i heard it was 22.
[Laughter]
you know why i drank so much because i
not let me cover this i had to realize
how much i had to pay an alimony for the
rest of my life
[ __ ] i run that you know i'd never heard
it put in that in those terms
and then when it did the next guy was
flying and we were i was gone well
like you they wasn't arrested some that
you were going to pay for their earlier
there's a lot of numbers
however you crunch the numbers it
doesn't look
uh but but but uh it's funny how people
get this [ __ ] wrong like i
you know i didn't get arrested right uh
you're just snoozing i just fell yeah
yeah
what casino was oh caesar's in windsor
canada oh windsor one of the great
one of the great sleeping because that
thing spread like wildfire overnight
yeah well it's a short news cycle too
still find those pants at my house
not not you [ __ ] again back in
the garage
yeah um yeah let's go what do we have uh
so we have the the barrett brothers we
have max and jack the creators of the
friday beers
brand friday beers big beers guys yeah
uh they just launched podcasts on our
network i'll let them
talk to you a little more about it but
uh yeah these are the masterminds behind
all your favorite
live-action memes but is it anything
like that you know when they would
you get to the internet like the beer of
the month club like they would send you
you remember that what was what was the
concept of that like if you picked they
would send you a different beer
every month like maybe four of them from
around the world do you guys remember
that i don't remember right
i know i've heard of it there was a club
that you could be
and they would send you beer from all
over the world sounds like we should
bring it back on their friday beer
i think it would be pretty good yeah
because you get beer that you couldn't
uh
ever get did you guys ever drink any uh
tenants
from glasgow scotland i've never had a
birthday i'm sure we've ran into
that's pretty big cannons tenants
tenants tannins are the thing in one
yeah that thing would [ __ ] you
lead-based
yeah one of the uh one that dad did work
that's right billy boyd i think so yeah
yeah like a personal connection they're
like
part of the town so so go
take me back to your history of beers
your father was your grandfather father
yeah both uh historic alcoholics
you know what you know and what is an
alcoholic is it a guy that falls asleep
with a casino or is it a guy that has
two shots that punches his wife i don't
know
we've got a scale struggle with that
definition too yeah yeah
um but i mean yeah the barrett family
history of beer
i'd
my dad is my dad is a has a saying when
he was like warning us to drink
responsibility
he was just listen jack like i know
it's in me because if i have one i want
to have two right if i have two
i want to have ten right yeah that's
right so that's sort of
that's the mentality we know that we
kind of have in our dna
but uh it's actually friday beers
is less about just like drinking a [ __ ]
ton of beer it's more about guys that
like
to drink beer it's about hanging out
hanging out with people when you're
drinking okay good
and like we started this uh basically
instagram account a year and a half ago
that was dedicated to the characters who
you're hanging out with when you're
when you start when we call it commence
and suck down when you when you start
drinking
something it's great they're all sort of
like any mess you gotta go for the whole
yeah i gotta have you guys uh
happy follow you that's awesome
i love that there's some like summer of
suckdown stuff going on right now right
right
we've called 2021 the summer of suckdown
because we lost the summer 2020. totally
so it's like woodstock but for sucking
down okay um
your workshop would suck for a while
you're like no that's not gonna
the pr guys throughout woodstock is
there what what what is uh what are some
of the beers
we'll go over what we started to drink
early on and yeah where did you guys
start around what
remember you guys probably i know who
said yeah yeah i mean honestly we
started drinking
bud lights bud light yeah yeah light
beers whatever is the cheapest and
easiest
available i i subsisted on keystone
light in college because you could get a
30 rack for 14 dollars at the local
uh we were doing uh the local things
called natty caddies
yeah yeah so let me
so here's here's the question um
the difference between like keystone and
and what's a hot blood light bloodline
what's the difference in the in the
beers
whatever whatever whatever it is yeah i
mean
if you're a working-class dude you know
like got my you know
they drank like paps yeah it's really
it's regional
they've drank there used to be a thing
out here in la off the five
freeway called brew 102 yeah
and that had uh a metal a fully metal
can
bottom which probably i think might
change the taste of beer
it could in a metal versus aluminum can
yeah yeah we we
actually we play a game with when when
people come over to our office
we have this game it's it's basically a
blind taste test of light beers
and you see if people really know miller
yeah that's great it's no one ever gets
no one right no one's ever gone perfect
four for four really
yeah it's i think what it comes down to
is like regionality
totally and bud light with a crisp
smooth fit
thank you bud you remember bud dry never
had a budget why ask why
what did i do what was that all about i
think it was
it might almost be like which is the one
that
lance armstrong was drinking uh um
michelob ultra
hgh it might be yeah adrian totally
at the bottom said the shaker yeah
the dudes that uh that are really heavy
and drink beer and enjoy it they're
never they never get any light on the
commercial today
those are what they should they should
they should absolutely those are our
heroes actually and those those
those inspire they're showing real dudes
yeah real dudes they inspire the friday
beers characters like we got characters
called the big fella
and that is your that is your friend who
is you know heavier guy
maybe he used to play college football
or something like that and he can put
down you know 28 beers in
two and a half hours and that that guy
deserves we like to celebrate characters
like that yeah
versus like hey jacked marketing
executive in the michelob ultra
commercial is uh
having a couple beers at like the nicest
bar you've ever seen triathlons yeah
right
right yeah that's not really
no it's not relatable to what you guys
are into but it's not relatable to what
the the beer culture is either i don't
think so no no i don't think so
i mean grant see jane's got the nice
haircut a nice tan maybe you know he's
maybe mick global
i tell you i did keto for a year if you
have done
one year that was the one beer you could
drink because there were like two cars
yeah
the venn diagram of people who have been
on keto diets and people who drink
mickle of all treasures
so they created almost like i don't want
to say backwash
but they created a beard that
they're like okay our other beers might
be better
bud you want locale but if you want
something that's that's almost it's
almost all duels right
right yeah it's pretty it doesn't have a
like a high abv
no alcohol by volume yeah but it
but it's still it's still like a beer
yeah yeah it's just on the lights and i
think like low
low carb in particular was like the
selling point and if somebody were to
give me a can
if somebody were to say but but a real
dude like the big dude is not going to
drink
no he's not going to go for nickelodeon
if you if you if he can't big fella is
just butt heavy
quite happy for him yeah i just love the
concept of butthead
yeah yeah those uh we went with uh in
the beginning we went with um
schlitz yeah such as the club
is like the class i feel like that was
the the mass consumption beer like the
pre
precursor to every one of them great
logo
metal can no frills maybe it didn't even
have anything other than just schlitz
and then they bumped up to schlitz malt
liquor yeah with the almost like the
detroit lions
uniforms yeah the the the silver with
the bull
yeah and uh they had that concept look
out for the ball and that [ __ ] would
[ __ ]
you up that's like you know rob a bank
after
three of them yeah yeah you wake up and
there's an atm in your garage
but that but but malt liquor is is a
different
uh that's not that's not beer it's malt
it's malt liquor
that can get dangerous i remember in
college and stuff when you'd have like a
call 45 or like an old
45 yeah it's a mall licker and a in a
tall
old english 800 yeah i mean i think
that's the beauty of
beer drinking is that you you know
you can pace yourself in a way where
you're either gonna get
like versus hard liquor or other types
of alcohol so we've been wanting like
you can pace yourselves and
you're either gonna get too full or
you're just gonna like get sleepy
you're not gonna have those moments
where you're like yeah you just totally
jump up a level and you're like oh no
something's happening can you see it
coming right so so so you can
you can feel better longer right
i like that and thank you welcome and
then you can have it and why don't you
look
at the tagline for a little bit better i
think
the guys that i grew up around i still i
still see them this guy that was in the
military doesn't drink
anymore for a long time and uh
we would be drinking beer like we were
cool drinking beer and then somebody
would say
hey let's do a shot and whenever they
say let's do a shot
everything after that is not about beer
anymore like i would have preferred to
have just say
you know what man let's just let's just
drink beer and chill watch tv and then
you get to that and you're not just
gonna do one shot and then now
your whole beard drinking experience
where you are feeling good
right now has has been destroyed by
this took a left turn but i'm with that
like if you got bring guys over
and they're just satisfied with just
sitting around and
tapping the bottom of the cam like those
do it like that
better than better than getting into
all eight shots for guys and then you
have a you probably have a night that
with the guys but you it won't be a good
night because they're going to get yeah
the next day that's awesome
so so so you guys have created a
podcast and a life and a variety and
style of beers where
i would say maybe wives aren't as
threatened as as we hope so and they're
actually included
right by the way yeah yeah so you said
like relatability earlier
like our whole thing when we started
friday beer's instagram account which
eventually became his podcast and
now other stuff we're doing like it's
better oh this is great it's just about
how how can we paint a picture of this
is these are the characters in your life
these are the guys you hang out with
these are the girls you hang out this is
what you do
this is how you feel on wednesday when
you're trying to get through the week
that's how you feel on friday we're like
oh [ __ ] yeah i made it
you get to that peak when you're just
about to come in suck down this is how
you feel on saturday when you're
in a bit of a sneaky bender we call it
being in the middle like this
or you're in the consumption vortex
where you're just drinking everything
that's coming at you yeah yeah yeah and
then sunday you're hungover you miss
your ex-girlfriend you want to order
some disgusting food to help you make
you feel better
everyone everybody feels like that to
some extent and we want to capture those
feelings okay so that's a that's a
problem a very good point yeah when i'm
hungover and
i try not i try not to be but
occasionally it gets man i've had some
[ __ ] horrible hangovers i can never
i can never eat but i know i should eat
right
and you probably should sleep and
i don't you need to get some greasy food
so and you're in the history of you guys
what are the top fives
best hangover food like and i think you
almost have to make yourself
eat even though you don't want to
you should because the longer you're on
an empty stomach and the longer the
worse your [ __ ] day is going to be
i so i used to live in new york and
actually i've never won customs by the
way i've never had that [ __ ] i used to
live in [ __ ] new york city
piece of [ __ ] whole town [ __ ]
butthole
and uh i actually never had a problem
with getting hungry after i drank i was
actually a ravenous appetite yeah but
what i would like to do on my worst
hangover day is
make a couch bed so i had like a couch
that would kind of fold out into a bed
and i would uh you know just have the tv
going on
straight couch bed sometimes my friends
would come over too and hang out on the
couch bed with me
and then i'd order from like eight
different takeout places i got a burger
from this place jg melon
i would get pizza from this place joe's
pizza get chinese from this place red
farm
and i would just you would stand around
the table and just have a little bit of
eating
more nice morsels of different cuisines
to get you through
and it would last it would be like a you
know four hour long buffet you could
just keep going but at the end of the
four hours you feel better
i would feel disgusting in a different
way it's really putting a band-aid
on like yeah
what creates uh what creates a hangover
no
it's a dehydration yeah dehydration yeah
like also like a lot of like sugar
you're drinking especially if you drink
liquor yeah it's
my sundays i just rotate between eating
pizza and jerking off the only
that's how you boot it up yeah you know
what i actually jacked up to one of the
napkins that i used when
and uh you know i'm not married when the
housekeeper comes over you know she has
her laundry list i have mine
[Laughter]
i'll take care of these because you know
you're in the car and hamper do not open
jack right by the side
so you know this [ __ ] disappeared i
bought i thought they were
missing some t-shirts and then and then
you'll find them in like i remember big
boy from
a radio i gave him a i gave him a jacket
that i had and he put his hand in his
pockets and pulled out some underwear
with [ __ ] all over him and he goes
go gee these that's you i said yeah
those are mine i would [ __ ] hide them
from my wife
and then you forget that me and [ __ ]
shoe trees i don't know who's in my
[ __ ] consoles are [ __ ]
shitty i shoot trees man you're like oh
those shoes are really keeping there
pull out my shoe trees and see and see i
mean nasty man
in those times you gotta and then you
take a couple of like uh tylenols with a
beer
and a and a little [ __ ] egg
muffin and i mean you're just trying to
get through the day
outer layer you feel immediately you
feel better
that's a good uh home remedy so as i've
gotten older
and i think you guys can um finally guys
that i can [ __ ] ask questions
is that this is higher in
in volume local so already very tight
half them already like a little yeah
yeah
right they're pint-sized classes is that
correct yeah yeah what makes a dude like
you know
so so let's say like the big a heavyset
dude that you drink with that's sitting
around
yeah just plowing beers yeah
the size is size relatable to
to tolerance or is is it
like would that guy be a lightweight no
no i i find that sizes
is often relatable yeah pretty yeah
pretty close correlation there's like
other stuff at play there but for the
most but like
just like you brought your if it's
harder or easier for your body to absorb
because there's just like
more fat and like it yeah it gets
absorbed in like the fat cells
i'm just skinny right now and i find
that my tolerance is like so low so it's
relatable too yeah
i think it's like honestly fat that you
have yeah and just like if you don't
eat and just less like [ __ ] inside your
body to like i don't know
absolutely soak it up that's gonna
that's gonna be directly affected and
by the way you're talking about how
tequila takes the left
the left turn of the night we've been
doing these event events lately
i want to go to one of your events oh
yeah what do one in l.a soon cool
um we're going we're doing a couple on
the east coast there we were in boston
last weekend it was on a
two parties on boats in boston oh [ __ ]
so you guys how many followers do you
guys have on your instagram
uh right now we're at 1.3 million yeah
um
yeah but uh and all of them aficionados
of beer
like they're aficionados of of hanging
out no yeah aficionados
i'm understanding weekend culture yeah
they're good times
yeah guy guys people girls girls people
who i mean the cliche like they they
work for the weekend which you know
right
which we all been doing for you today
yeah uh so yeah
we get to drink beers they're all very
late afternoon with george today
like-minded in that stuff so you guys
you have a promoter and all that stuff
for you well
promoters will come to us and like hey
can you come to boston and so these guys
set us up on these boats
and we did one in new york july 4th
weekend anyways
i was i disobeyed all my cardinal rules
in new york
right now i got out of the beer stick to
beer situation and the cassia's
guy brought out a beer bong and they
were pouring sangria into the beer ball
and i was like you know i'm gonna go
shop for shot with this guy tonight and
i basically it was our first big event
of the summer and i uh
you know got taken home at 11 30. i
don't remember anything yeah it was
it was one of those moments where i know
jack very well we're we're brothers
um and so i've seen jack yeah i know
i know he's like your body his behavior
i can see when his behaviors are
starting to be
veered into the oh he's getting too
drunk territory sort of lights around
how did you make the hard right lights
on but nobody's going you know you were
going you know you were going in that
direction right because
you immediately listen yeah i've been
drinking since i was 13. i've never
had [ __ ] sangria out of a beer bunny
yeah i was the first time i
i've never seen it i've never seen it
shout out this guy two turns
hey greg well you're doing a [ __ ]
beautiful job man you left the pockets
oh no that so
our computers were [ __ ] all right
it's fixed just take the hitch and say
sorry george
it was it was also it was it was at an
italian restaurant
yeah and uh i'm sitting there
in my head i know like okay jack is on a
slippery slope
i don't i i i trusted him i was like
maybe he he's he's
not that drunk we get to the venue and
or
it's a concert so there's three
different acts and the
first performers on very sparse crowd no
one's really there yet right but jack's
already on stage like oh [ __ ] wait i'm
like all right dude this is not
the moment i do not know actually like
pumping up the 15 people in the crowd
they need to get pumped up they
appreciate it yeah
every 15 people have their own hype man
yeah so we changed the regiment for
boston and yeah
we uh they were like um you know you
guys we gotta do this tequila we gotta
get this vodka to drink and i was like
no let's just skip some bud lights and
pacificos and yeah yeah
stuck to the diary of just bud lights
after bud lights
and it you know we had a great time i
got a little tired and sleepy honestly
so the guys that the guys who enjoy beer
yeah um are they sticking to just the
same beer all the time
they don't they don't move around do
they i mean i think
uh there are some people who are like
really loyal to a certain brand
and like they are like pbr but
in general i mean if you yeah i think
most beer drinkers
that like the beauty of it is like how
diverse it is and like you can try like
you know ipas and you have your light
beers and
right you got tasting flights and
there's like a there's a whole world
of beer that's like big world constantly
like you're fine you discover new things
and
the new tastes and and uh that's like
there's an excitement behind it
um that is i think different than some
other other types of liquor
but let's say like gordon biersch and
that kind of stuff where they do the
beer
there or you know when they started to
do craft beers and microbrews yeah we're
you're not i respect those guys but
that's not what friday appears
right now yeah it's just like if i don't
have this by smuttynose ipa i won't have
an ipa tonight yeah right
every beer tastes good to me and i think
i think that's probably what most of our
fans feel
is just like this will get the job done
like we celebrate all
shapes and sizes you know what the
colors the thing about the thing about
beer
is you could watch a softball game with
some kids you never met
yeah and if you sat there in your chair
with your 12-pack just reaching down
into it you don't have to look
you know what's there and you're sitting
there immediately bonding you would have
an
incredible time hey where did your son
play i don't have a [ __ ] song i'm
just watching
i'm trying to play on aaron's softball
team but he says they can't drink during
the at the la park so i
lost a little bit of momentum well that
was yeah one thing
wait a minute wait a minute you can't
drink in la park no
yeah i learned that over the pandemic
because i technically because i'd be
going out there with friends and we'd
have drinks and like oh after a couple
are done a couple of times
wait a minute no wait wait wait wait a
guy walks up like you can't do that
right
but at the beach they come around those
atvs and look at it and see if you're
drinking
yeah but this is new to me at the at the
at the la parks you can't drink beer
can't drink beer at the park right here
if you had a birthday party you couldn't
have beer there
you have to be sneaky about it but yeah
yeah
i mean it i don't i don't think it was
never an issue
you could have it out like who's the
[ __ ] go to the park that's almost
like going to a [ __ ] skating rink man
you can't wear [ __ ] skates in here
they go around they write tickets to
people that are drinking beer like at a
baptism at the park
baptism there's not a ton of baptisms
either
yeah wow it depends where you live but
yeah right okay
yeah yeah but yeah i mean when people
come up to me it's always i mean they've
always been like
hey bro like this is so stupid but
you're not allowed to drink that out
here technically like put it away so i
don't get in trouble like
no one's been a dick about it but they
enforce it
what are the what are the guy guys
drinking in boston what what's the best
oh sam adams
sam adams is like the boston beer right
also shout out
cisco brewers they have a big thing
going on in northeast in boston and uh
we're gonna go
have an event at their brewery in two
weeks but that's
in boston as well they have one in
boston they have one in nantucket and
other places but
i think sam adams would lay claim to
boston so sam adams all
they have a lot of different kinds of
beers right yeah and then they even have
like uh
apple yeah they got tons of pumpkins
yeah yeah yeah but
but wherever they brew wherever their
brewery is like how long have they been
in
brewing for a long time a hundred years
yeah yeah but like
i
[Laughter]
but sam adams is uh i would say
one of those beers that you can drink in
the backyard you could drink it at an
event you could drink it at the park you
could drink out of the water ballpark
it's a it's a it's a great brand of beer
right like if you
because they've got variety but you know
that you're not going to go wrong with
with any salmon they've got so they've
got like boston loggers like they're
classic like
i guess marquee one then that in the
summer summer ale
winter winter longer beautiful that's
marketing man they got the
oktoberfest i got my wife just divorced
me oh i'll have that lager yeah
that god damn barely failed a bottle
yeah and
also for reference because i am older
than you guys every
car accident and if they left the car
there while they were waiting to tow it
had a mickey's big mouth in the front
seat every
every accident that was caused by
somebody drinking
had you know the mickey have you seen
the mickey's big mouth right now it's
like a malt liquor but it looks like a
barrel it's a green glass
and it looks like a barrel and the mouth
of the [ __ ] [ __ ] is that big
like you when you open it it had like a
pool top almost like a
shrimp cocktail yeah that's like a
campbell soup
yeah yeah and you'd pop it open and you
would go like that out of the [ __ ] i
mean it's that
wide and that it's like a like just like
a cup with extra steps
yeah yeah and two of those it was i
think mickey's big mouth was
it's irish i haven't believed that i
think so i can see why that that'll [ __ ]
you up too
and the main selling point is just how
easy yeah yeah yeah
faster but that's against the kind of
that's against the theory of you guys
right is to be
driving completely blacked out let us be
clear we do not endorse that no no not
at all operating any type of heavy
machine no but this is just
the thing that's great yeah uh
i think the guys that i grew up with
that we we grew up drinking like we
would go to the tequila but i think we
would have had a better time just
just chilling well you don't have many
options when you're young like that like
you're gonna
drink paint thinner if you don't want
that know where the [ __ ] you got this
idea
we drank some uh slow gin fizz
okay i think i don't know i've ever had
slow gin before i know
you know what slow gin is i don't know
so slow gin i think it's it's like it's
it's it's an alcohol and then you i'm
gonna see if i can pull it out it's in a
slow gin fizz
anyway presumably and
you and then you mixed it with like
strawberry soda like nesbits
yeah strawberry soda
that's right we went to go get some more
strawberry soda i backed into a [ __ ]
car at the liquor store
on uh laurel canyon and chest and chats
were bam
dude came out [ __ ] didn't see it
really i [ __ ] died at that [ __ ]
slow chin man
yeah well yeah we left we yeah that
night could have been brutal
but it didn't take long for all of us to
be
fast times on slow gin yeah so i've
never heard of this i'm looking it up
i don't think any of those dudes have
have ever had slow gin after that i know
i haven't
well it's not like slow like the
opposite of fast either oh
yeah which is some i'm still trying to
find out it's
it's made by soaking slows so whatever
the [ __ ] it is
it's awesome it's awful but yeah that's
some fancy [ __ ]
the world is racing to get back to
normal and start meeting up in person
again but after the year that we've all
had
getting back and feeling normal takes
time i have been in a
therapy or around a therapist for 21
years
and you know i used to think i was alone
but
having somebody that you could talk to
makes all of the difference so if you're
feeling overwhelmed by all this
know that you're not alone and find the
support that you need to face those
feelings and move forward a lot of times
you can't really talk to the people that
are in your life it should be something
that
from someone who's a trained
professional not someone who's going to
tell you
you know what i checked out i wasn't
listening so get
unbiased feedback and advice from a
personal
licensed professional and you know that
makes all the difference it's refreshing
it's rewarding
and when you're in a low point you might
feel like you're alone but over 50
percent
of americans struggle with their mental
health so don't feel like you're ever
alone and don't feel like you have to
struggle
with your mental health and take it from
somebody who's alone a lot of times i've
been talking to somebody for
21 years and i don't think i could have
said any of that
to any of my friends or family so know
that you're not alone
and mental health is a serious serious
issue especially after
the year that we've had so start feeling
better you can feel better with a single
message try it out
i mean you know hey they match you with
a licensed therapist when you go to
talkspace.com you get 100
off your first month with the promo code
omg hi
that's a hundred dollars off when you
use the code
omg hi at talkspace.com
good luck you know the world is starting
to uh open up again and the performance
package 4.0 from manscape
is here to help you get ready inside you
will find
the lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker
uh
ear and nose hair trimmer listen man as
you get older as you're a guy
you need to take care of the things that
you can't
see hair on your nose that's long hair
in your ears that's long
and if you get to uh you know the golden
palace down there you
you want your foliage to be top notch
and
and manscape and the larmor 4.0 trimmer
and the weed whacker and the ear nose
trimmer
this will make you look better than you
are rightly should look
tight clean those crazy ass eyebrows
nobody should have those
so a world-class discount in this
post-quarantine
uh world this package is the perfect
package
for your package your huevos your pedals
and big performance
and you know what you don't feel bad you
know when you're dropping those
and they're taken care of there you know
it's like when someone's house is dirty
and you go
oh don't mind the mess but then they're
inside they're like this place is a
[ __ ] dump
now you keep your hair right you look
right and when your hair looks right
uh down there the world is right so the
lawnmower 4.0 which is what i have
has a 7 000 rpm motor
those pubes even the stubborn ones never
had a chance and they can't hide
in their like around the taint so this
is where we're at
uh get 20 off free shipping with the
code
omg hi at manscape.com
that's 20 off free shipping with the
code
omghi at manscape.com oh my god hi
and achieve pubic glory this year
with manscaped and
it'll be so smooth she won't know
your secret
i live alone so the great thing about
green chef is that it lets you choose
from a wide array of easy to follow
recipes
perfect for uh keto and paleo
and plant power diets or even if you
just want to eat a more balanced
uh way you know they have a healthy
food healthy lifestyle and it makes it
easier to kind of eat at home
and you're cooking dinners and stuff
that everything is all well balanced and
you're not trying to put something
together
everything is hand-picked featuring
organic veggies high-quality proteins
delivered to your door pre-measured and
mostly prepped in insulated
packages that's very important so you
know
i've done um green chef and
i got to tell you man like even if you
get home and you open the refrigerator
something is waiting for you as opposed
to having to eat maybe 45 minutes later
so um you know tell me what's your
favorite
green chef recipe if you're just
starting a green chef good luck because
it's awesome man
and green chef saves you time
and why be putting the thing together in
the kitchen when
green chef will help you out get you
back to
gaming or watching tv or just chilling
faster than normal
go to greenshift.com
100 and use the code omg hi100 to get
100 off
including free shipping all right free
shipping that's a big deal
so that's greenchef.com omghi
100 and use the code omg hi 100 to get
100 off
including free shipping green chef the
number one meal kit
for eating well if you haven't done it i
recommend that you do it
and do it with your wife and do it with
your family and do with your kids and
you all will be eating better and no one
will have to be embarrassed
because they decided to eat better while
everybody else is still eating the same
way
go green chef and get all on the same
page because that's good
it's it's that time after this year we
need to start eating good
and better and feel better and be better
[Music]
so you're talking about drinking um at
like a random softball game
with you guys there's no better example
of that when you go to a baseball game
and you start out you like sit in this
section and some dudes
don't know each other seventh inning
teams winning
arms around each other cheers in buying
each other beers
hey you know throw me that dip or
whatever like yeah just
instantaneous bonds over these type of
overtaking so so what's happening at
at sporting events dude when the when
dudes are like knuckling up
like they're just over served yeah i
think and i think they're
i think they're probably drinking like
[ __ ] whiskey at the game that's
that's the thing like the
the beer drunk is no it's a usual
i've got a great saying is my friend my
friend otto
uh who coined this uh is it better than
mine what was mine
the one i said earlier which oh feel
better for longer if you don't like feel
better
no that's really good but he coincides
with college guys the beer drunk
is the best drunk and thus the hardest
to achieve
yes you have to really work for it and
that's it's just like a jolly good time
drunk
right you have to get to uh yeah yeah a
bit more harmless then
yeah yeah you
one of those guys that's like a like a
beer drinker like a guy's guy
can one of those guys lose it and start
grabbing people and wanting to fight
i think only one under uh duress i think
it's
backed into a corner yeah yeah because
alcohol makes alcohol gets that
that's when you're really gonna do that
yeah but if you're drinking beer
i don't think the guy who drinks beer is
going looking for a fight i think the
guy who's ripping jmo shots it's going
to
fall yeah and he probably has a tiny
penis
it also really depends how bad the game
is going right
right i don't know just like there's a
lot i mean that's a big thing but i feel
like
la you know you hear about like the la
da and the uh
giants like brawls in the stands and
stuff like that it's a lot of [ __ ] like
that happens out here like where we're
from in new york like i don't even
like feel like a yankee stadium maybe
that guy got kicked at yankee statement
throwing a ball at a
red sox player yesterday yeah
and you know as much as as many baseball
fans go to baseball like
millions of them over the years and i've
been going to dodger stadium since 1967
yeah
i've never seen a [ __ ] player get hit
with another call from a fan
yeah yeah it's nuts that guy's banned
from all 30 baseball stadiums now oh
really yeah lifetime
i just didn't see the throw was it very
intentional like he i didn't see the
throw either did you see it throw in
it during the conversion okay so they
didn't even get the
it on film but because he was sitting
like pretty high in the uh
yeah bleachers got a good arm kind of
cannon
today
he's not allowed to stand on the thirty
but i see that more now and well because
also also remember like you know now
all those stadiums have [ __ ] hard
liquor
and you can get oh yeah [ __ ] tequila
you couldn't cost 38 bucks but you can
get a double shot or whatever
but you couldn't get any of that [ __ ]
back before it was beer hot dogs
yeah peanuts yeah cracker jacks that was
it
yeah and now i think with all that when
welcome to the johnny walker
uh suite where we can have any type
we'll have a waitress come over to me
so so when i would go to dodger games i
used to sit right behind home plate and
i'd get margaritas and then you know
your every pitch your own home plate
sorry like
a [ __ ] [ __ ] would send me a
message and then you go like hey man
that's your third margarita
right yeah so yeah
how do they know so i told the the
waitress i said hey can you bring me
like a margarita but put it in like a
coke
cup with a lid and then your next
[ __ ] message what are you a [ __ ]
diabetic
that's your fourth diet culture [ __ ] man
like they they count your [ __ ] cup
and i would never leave like well when i
was going to baseball games or events my
gran with my grandfather
he you know just said sixth inning he'd
go let's go
let's get this like it's one nothing
right i don't have to leave he was my
right and now
i never never leave so especially when
you're sitting behind a play if i left
there would be like oh no it's bad
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's bad luck but
but i think that
directly relatable is that
like sometimes people get tickets that
wouldn't necessarily be
behind home plate and then it comes with
the never ending oh i love watching
who is down there yeah and all of these
uh
a lot of these new stadiums have like
such good hospitality when you get to
sit down there too
and you can have it probably has amazing
hospitality i've never been there yet
yeah and and if you get a ticket from
your boss or somebody like that
they won't stop is all these comedy have
tickets you can take us to the dodgers
again uh not
currently yeah we're working on that
boxing okay yeah
one of the classic ballparks and
stadiums in america but
but then also like stadiums have have
contracts with
certain we're not even beer company but
but a certain
organ like arthur or whatever that they
do and then you have to get what
what they have what they provide yeah
yeah that's [ __ ] up they won't let me
bring
my 30 rack of bud lights or you can't
get it no natty cat he's in
yeah or you can't you can't get but like
they like
at dodger stadium they had this thing uh
estrella
yeah estrella galicia i think yeah
jalisco that's jalisco yeah what is it
that's a new
uh anheuser-busch beer i thought they
were making a [ __ ] movie i said
when does this come out yeah but it's
their version of what's going on
yeah like uh they've got theirs yeah
it's like a mexican lager yeah is it
good
i haven't had it did we have it uh yeah
maybe try that it's good
someone here likes them yeah yeah yeah
they spent a lot of money
yeah on that how did you guys how did
the original idea come about
so what we were doing before we started
friday beers is we were like writing
sketch comedy
and we were doing that for like you know
four or five years
we uh basically we had an instagram
account called 20 something comedy
and we would make sketches write them
act in them
edit them put them on our little
instagram account and we could never
like really break like a critical
threshold of like 8 000 followers yeah
and we were also
working we were working full-time jobs
right and this is kind of the side
hustle
uh yeah just it was like kind of in an
efficient in the sense
it takes a long time to make sketches
and then people on instagram
like they don't have the attention span
to watch like two minutes because when
you guys open the account
you didn't really have a following or
anything like nothing and you just did
it on based on
what we used to get a big following was
instead of like going out and filming
your own sketches we just
took footage from tv shows movies
sports put up music behind it yeah and
then we used text on top of those
right just started like telling the
jokes that we were writing our own
sketchbook
so talk about relatability people like
see clip from old school it's always
sunny they see a clip from an nfl game
that that drew them in really well that
allowed them to understand the jokes
that we were telling
and that allowed them to understand the
characters we were introducing
and that just started jumping and
jumping and jumping yeah it really is
genius i don't know if you had a chance
to like check out much of them or
anything but like
they take these you know there's the
iconic scene that you're already sort of
like talking with your
friends about like i remember growing up
it's like you know there wasn't barely
even comedy you just like tell anchorman
jokes to each other
and this is like the sort of modern take
on that where everyone still has those
same sort of like touch points
yeah they're like oh yeah [ __ ] it like
old school and anchorman and all that
[ __ ]
and like the way that you can sort of
you know you've built the characters
over time and
the way you can just slot them all in
like you can tell sketches with other
people's content
you can make sketches of other people's
content and max and i have a pretty deep
knowledge of like
movies and especially comedy movies and
tv shows because again as grant was
saying
growing up it's just all about how many
what movies and tv shows
[Laughter]
yeah and which one is it in uh
in old school uh hang the tank frag the
tag
tank that's a big fall that's a big one
yeah yeah that's yeah
that's probably one of our most used
clips yeah yeah i mean that's what goes
like that
yeah i mean once it hits your lips it's
so good there's not a better quote
though tastes so good
the comedy that shaped us growing up and
yeah and the comedy that
kind of you know died out uh over the
past decade
and that we were kind of jack and i were
searching like you know how do we
i think it's [ __ ] died out over
because of political correctness right
and and you know for good reason a lot
of like those movies
have not aged well and you know couldn't
be remade
the same way today and and rightfully so
but
there are elements of that that comedy
and that the universe are
always going to be funny and relatable
we just wanted to find a way to tell
them in 2021
that that's the way people are telling
those stories yeah you know it's
pretty simple it's like just be
self-deprecating first and foremost like
don't punch down
yeah and like you can still tell those
jokes and you're not going to offend
anyone yeah
uh and i don't and like we just we're
like we just didn't want to give up on
that brand of humor because we loved it
so much
right uh and we found a way to kind of
repurpose it and and uh
it still resonates with people yeah
that's something you call them live
memes or
something live action i've heard live
action memes live-action memes that's
right
which i did because i'm i mean i'm about
to i mean the characters myself
give me give me the well there's a lot
of i mean
well you know even like in all the
family or things like that where
if you're if you were doing a sitcom
back in the day like the father would
come home and get a beer
right al bundy and right and and
the original they were politically
correct yeah
right it took away the you know archie's
place that they had that bar they would
go to
you know um uh when
this is when i was doing my show when i
got signed into a show bruce helford had
done drew carey and then they always had
a bar they went to
right is drew carey on that list that
would meet me you know
uh probably we don't use auditor carry
the the
jot it uh for us people forget about
that show
yeah they do forget about that show it
was big and then uh
uh he said to me you know you need to
find a place that
um that you know you would go to
you know and i worked on i worked on
ramer and sepulveda
at itt and bob bonner this guy probably
shouldn't his real name bob bonner and i
would go he would say
hey man you're thirsty and i would say
what time is it like you know it's like
11 45 yeah
i'm thirsty so there was maybe about a
quarter of a mile up there was a strip
club called thirsties
of beer and like pasta pretty good food
we would go over there and knock out a
couple pictures of beer at lunch and
then watch
these girls dance in front of us it was
like a red barn yeah
and sorry where did you say this was i
don't think it's there
and uh god and then thirsties right so
so that's so good
when they asked me on my show like we
need a place to to where you guys could
go after work i said
i said how about thirsties and then
bruce is like oh that's a [ __ ] great
name what's that
i said it's this place you know so
thirsty so we went to thirsties
they said yes they started using
thursday are you shooting it there yeah
no no we used the name
and we created the bar on the stage yeah
yeah and then uh
uh i have actual thirsty's door for my
show at my house wow
oh that's awesome when you walk in if
you see the show and then one day
my wife when i was married my wife comes
in and i think the show was already over
and she goes
hey um i was driving on sepulveda
and thirsties is a strip club
i'm like what no
[Laughter]
where you could go during the day
and you know you don't want to put the
clientele was
dudes would sit around in the afternoon
and have beer and watch girls
dance and have [ __ ] spaghetti
spaghetti
i didn't have a problem with it i did
not have an issue with
yeah you know i also drink beer earlier
the world's favorite beer you like
ronald reagan said you know he's like
you're eating ice cream in the snow on
the cold day and he's like when you like
ice cream
you eat it at any time i get another
need to be hot to eat ice cream i drink
beer first thing in the morning i was
saying in my family you can't drink all
day if you don't start in the morning
brush your teeth yeah but all that stuff
is uh
like i think of all of the things that
are out there it's it's the safest of
all the
of all the things to drink it's the most
relatable
alcoholic beverage out there it's the
every man have you guys been to chicago
and done anything in chicago yet
well i've been to we've been to chicago
but now not for friday beers
because one of the ironic parts of us
starting the account is
it coincided with like the worst time
for like going to bars
ever so we you guys filled that void
yeah i have a proposal for us okay okay
we if you guys are into it across the
street from
wrigley field i'm into it i got you all
ready yeah
there's a statue of harry carey yeah and
i went to this place i'll tell you the
name there's a military dude there
we're drinking drinking beer and you
know the base of the statue is pretty
high like
yeah maybe like this high yeah yeah and
that this dude jumped on the
he jumped on the bar from a standing i
mean only with beer can you do that
you know we're not going to be sitting
around at a seminar going you know i can
[ __ ] stand i can jump from a stand
still on this table nobody's going to do
that right sober so
in the bar they go yeah they're in the
bar they go this dude any
stand in there yeah he jumped up and he
landed
with with room to spare he didn't go
like this he went up there
and you're like that's [ __ ]
impressive as [ __ ] so we go outside
there's a harry kerry statue
with the base of it is a little bit
higher yeah
and he [ __ ] did it outside too so you
want us to go try it
no i want us to go and do a beer event
at murphy's bleachers which is across
the street from
100 percent that's where we have
murphy's bleachers if you're out there i
don't know yeah
yeah we're going to come over and we're
going to we're going to have an event we
got to i wish
we actually could go to chicago in the
summer because chicago in the summer is
like one of the greatest cities in the
world it's great
it's a business you're talking about
drinking early how do they have it in
chicago where people just like don't
work on fridays
they play the cubs games at like noon at
one and
everyone's in the bar at 10 a.m i know
but you know
awesome because like they've always done
it
yeah and the soul of that place is not
like here
right and you can walk to places that
helps too closing down thirsties
i think the biggest thing is that you
can walk to the stadium and get on the l
yeah and you can get home like you don't
you're not
nobody's in the car right right but they
also drink
and they can handle it it's like a drink
because you drink you eat 16 kill bosses
while you're
drinking exactly we were drinking over
there i threw out the first pitch and
sang you know
a couple of times nice or the seventh
inning stretch yeah and you know
they bring like that card of dessert
right you know we're hammered
oh yeah i grabbed some [ __ ] candy
apples and over the thing
on the on the suite where the sweets are
there's a whole group of people over
there that are under kind of like the
bleacher
down the third base line so i started
grabbing like a big bag of m
m's and stuff and start throwing candies
and marshmallows and eminem's yeah
[ __ ] you must have loved all this so
so they're going yeah they're all
[ __ ] cheering
and then the lady comes in she taps me
and she gives me a piece of paper
[ __ ] 350
a [ __ ] [ __ ] candy
yeah it's like like this of eminem yeah
yeah like that of
reese's pieces have you ever been to the
bar sluggers outside of what really
fields no they're the batting cages
there
so they're nice they have batting cages
in the bar so every time
it seems like a liability into a cubs
game
i like i gotta go take bp at sluggers
just like you know all right
half to murphy's bleachers and half the
sluggers done
that that is actually one of the biggest
like no i won't say bucket list but like
targets for us to get to
friday beers just do that yeah can we do
it yeah great set it up right now i
don't know
let me just text my guys
yeah it would be amazing yeah that'd be
awesome yeah really would be we could do
it in august
yeah i'm going to try to do one thing
while while we're here
you could do it around like next uh
paddy's day where they turn the river
fully
fully dude yeah chicago
st patrick's day is like you better be
wearing tactical gear but i don't think
they throw man they just have fun i
don't think they're
oh yeah i think they're throwing
nobody's throwing blows i do feel like
you always get like a surprisingly
good like report the next day where it's
like chicago was crazy but
pretty much everyone just had a good
time
yeah what are the what are the movies
that that are relatable
uh beer wise
i mean our canon of movies is like old
school anchorman
billy madison happy gilmore uh i mean i
said you know
dumb and dumber caddyshack yeah are
there any uh any
like more recent because i feel like you
guys are hitting this honestly
not so many like what was the last year
they made
in the early 2000s what was the last
year they made a movie that
that people we did we did this exercise
recently
and it's like it's hard to find one past
like 2010.
yeah hangover was maybe like the last
one that we like frequently draw
from um which was what 2008. it's like
yeah yeah yeah yeah but yeah i mean
that's like there was a decade
where there was a huge absence people
don't really go
for making like those sort of like laugh
out loud r-rated no
uh comedies anyone there was i never
even saw it so i'm like
kind of case in point but it was that
will ferrell uh amy poehler the house
or something like that remember it
seemed like it was going to be a house
yeah
i got sent that script the house script
was great and the
the movie was not like it was really
cool because they were running like a
casino in somebody's house
yeah i was going to break legs and they
had like the councilman and all that
stuff
yeah it didn't translate it feels like
for the past decade like the business
part of show business was just like yeah
i don't want to do this
anymore for some reason but i'm hopeful
especially with streaming and
peacock right hopefully that's good but
then like um
but then like something like old school
that's like 2004
for yeah yeah where are the crashers and
also
and also those guys weren't really known
yet
oh yeah yeah that was like sort of their
first answer
yeah and i don't think you know i know
luke i don't think they even knew
what was really kind of happening until
they were done
right yeah i don't know it'd just be
just it's such a good concept now i read
that i was
on the plane the other day and i was
just reading the uh description of old
school like the delta description was
like
2 30 something like a group of 30
something tries to like relive their
college lawyers like that is so
oh yeah yeah i showed it to my daughter
my daughter's 25 and she's like uh
i'm she's amazed
i watched all the school first time i
was 14 and i didn't know what fraternity
was
so yeah i watched when i was 14 watching
i was 19 which i was 24 watched i was 29
like it just gets better every time i
walk
part of the responsibility we feel with
friday beers is to kind of educate
gen z about this this lost arab comedy
well time came
people were like what is you know yeah
what is old school
caddyshack good neighbor stuff all the
sketch comedy they don't know about it
they've like never seen zoolander before
yeah but they're like
it's it is fun and they've probably
never even seen it they've probably
never even seen a movie before
they're probably they they're all
watching quizzes so
where is the where is the associated
tick-tock dance i do
but also confused i know it's a big deal
when you saw like somebody drinking an
actual [ __ ]
well back then you could drink a beer
with the can in it you didn't have to
try to hide [ __ ] from anybody because
everything was so kind of undiscovered
yet
right that people weren't offended if
you pulled out you were sitting there
with a [ __ ] budweiser drinking a
budweiser like it wasn't
you needed to get money to do it right
right right right oh yeah oh like are
you talking about within movies
like no money and they
yeah i mean really of all the of all the
movies like yeah
that's an interesting comparison too
because first of all we love
animal house we love caddyshacks um
and we actually love a lot of like what
national lampoon like represented in the
late 70s
we actually would like to become like
sort of national lampoon like 2021 that
would be awesome
because it was guys in their like you
know mid-20s into their 30s capturing
this like
sort of lifestyle around party culture
in a really smart way and they had
traditions and sayings and characters
and it lived in a radio show and a
magazine and movies
and we're sort of like if we can make a
character universe that's like
resonates with that audience like what
would prevent us from doing like
sort of what national lampoon could do
you know what i
i don't think any i don't think anything
i think the time is right as you know as
generations go
and that kind of national lampoon you
guys probably got older right
right right it's hard to pass yeah a
mantle like that because so much of it i
don't think was even structured right no
it was just
yeah and i think the brand still exists
to some degree
actually i think we did a podcast with
them at one point but like
it's been so like corporatized bought
out by private equity yeah sort of thing
that is just it's kind of a name at this
point but also you know if there's that
document about cream magazine that music
magazine
and it was a [ __ ] dude that just like
rock and he created his magazine yeah
and he had his hands in it and then
you know they just started had that that
boy howdy guy the can
and they started to do like the t-shirts
and the magazine which
wasn't just other than a dude that loved
rock like you guys beer
we love we love hanging out with our
friends and drinking babies and
when those bands would come that guy
would go over there and interview him
and they would do this thing he was cool
was a big fan
and then it grew from that but that's
kind of and then
what changed it was that you know they
make a bid to buy your company
you would never think no i'm not going
to sell this and then yeah and then it
goes away but they were doing it you got
to see that thing it's great
it was anything like that lampoon
documentary i would be all over it was
it like
drunk heist bro the doug kenny
documentary is different but the uh
stupid and futile gesture
yeah yeah that's the only biopic yeah
which is great great movie i thought
yeah it was a joel um
joel mchale like playing young chevy
chase right yeah yeah yeah
that which i just thought was so good
but the yeah the whole thing with that
is like there's still
25 year olds like aren't going anywhere
yeah
you know in fact there's a new group of
25 year olds every year that's that
thing about 25 years what do they do
they don't do anything no they just like
when you're in that phase you're like
i'd say anywhere from like 18 to 35 like
you just all like your priorities like
are
your friends like you're still figuring
out what you're doing like career-wise
we're all [ __ ] still figuring it out
like all these things are like so
paramount like what you're doing on the
weekends are things that keep you going
that if there's no like if there's no
comedy platform that speaks to those
kids right
or that generation like that's a huge
bummer
like they there's so much humor in that
well i mean think about that you're
absolutely right i mean
think about i saw animal house at a
drive-in
i saw up in smoke at the drive and i saw
the next movie the driver and i saw
all those movies in the 70s that were
[ __ ] badass yeah
in hardly ever in the theater and you
you could sneak beer into
not sneak it
hey come on now forget it yeah so in
pacifico first i went to i went to
ensenada and then i saw pacifico this
was like in the mid 80s and i had a
couple of pacificos and you're like this
is the most [ __ ] amazing bridge it's
tasty
that blue and that brown bottle yeah so
i take literally like a hundred and four
plus if he goes and i shove him into my
toyota celica under the seat
behind the thing like they're they're
all over the place yeah and i think
there's two of us so i think i'm going
to be
[ __ ] cool i go up to the border
patrol guy goes he [ __ ]
goes like this and i pull over and he
goes
before he knew what was in there
were you taking all this beer the
[ __ ] knew exactly what i had in
there
and those guys are [ __ ] i i guess
because you see all these cars like
maybe you know when the dude has a
blower or something yeah normally a
driver's here and i was okay
and and and those dudes were laughing
as they pulled beer out of almost
everywhere you could pull the beer out
of them or they had an extraction
oh yeah and that they were drinking them
two hours later yeah i'm sure they were
there was a guy in chicago too when i
was there in the 80s and i was smoking a
cigar in a in a club you could smoke a
cigar and this guy goes well is that a
cuban cigar
and i go yeah and he goes let me see and
petrol feels like a cohiba
and he goes like this and he's got a
ziploc bag
of like 50 cigars and he goes what about
these and like jesus christ
did you get those he goes i work for
customs
double dipper dude
if you're going through customers and
they find [ __ ] and they're able to keep
it and take it home yeah you wouldn't
want to work for customers
yeah it's like it's literally your job
oh my god just like if you lose your
[ __ ] ipad on the plane
you're not getting it is there a lost
and found you go
it's like over there one shirt yeah
yeah there's never any bundles of cash i
don't think they could take as many
things they used to be able to before
there was a camera on everybody
george just said remind me he's like
that was when you still smoke cigars
inside by the way
yeah it's like you just met we have a
character in our sketch podcast
who's like we call him the old timer and
he's like reminiscing how to be like how
things used to be can i be like can i do
yeah yeah
you can log in yeah it's it's great the
first one just came out so he's like
he's like
you know you're just talking about this
is why you could smoke cigars inside our
version of old timer
he's actually 29.
he's reminiscing about like a time that
was just like two years ago and trying
to seem like older than he is no
so he goes he's talking about smoking a
jewel yeah an easy cigarette
like you're trying to extend it yeah he
goes that was when you still could smoke
a jewel inside by the way
but you could you could do that yeah so
so
anybody between 25 and 35 they're not
they're not going anywhere huh
when they go to vegas what are they
doing you know it's interesting because
vegas i think has changed so much
because now it's all trying to cater
to like the 20 to 35 year olds so basis
is all about like
pool parties night clubs you know all
places people get [ __ ] the gambling side
of vegas
is not really like catering towards the
kids
they're all [ __ ] they don't have
anything you know yeah people got
students everyone's there
on a credit card exactly yeah so you
know my daughter went last weekend and
then you know she
you she took some friends with her and i
got her in to see a couple of
the chain smokers and this other right
and then she get a [ __ ] message
saturday mid-afternoon hey so do i have
to tip these guys
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] of course you're
talking about
i only have eighty dollars i'm like
[ __ ] vegas without any [ __ ] money
yeah
and then i go i i go well you know
sean's out there works with santana you
know
and he goes he's got some money goes no
i know i don't i don't need that but but
i mean
[ __ ] calls him up and says hey can
you drop off 500 at my hotel
and she hasn't called me and told me
that she did that although you know
no yeah yeah surprisingly weird guys
no no i said how much i'm like mine what
the [ __ ] who
[ __ ] who raised you what's the
[ __ ] dude
there you go with my man yeah what the
[ __ ]
and you know what those [ __ ] tickets
are like to go see those dudes oh yeah
the [ __ ] 4 000. yeah they got 12 000.
yeah oh yeah that's where they make
their money like the bottle service and
the
tables but no performer there's not a
four thousand dollar ticket
in vegas is there not to see usher or
anything like that right or gaga
they're not fortunate no it's all i
think when you see the
the dj's it's a whole different ball
game like in terms of pricing because
it's the
liquor that you buy yeah i mean you're
buying tables you're buying bottles
that's what bud light costs 18 bucks
yeah and you're there for like
six hours yeah yeah you know but
but um in my day here's my e-cigarette
yeah
my day yeah the pool was i i guess now
potentially space that they could have
had a party out there
it was all about the night time okay
yeah yeah actually
i just watched the frank sinatra
two-part documentary
which was like when vegas was real vegas
that's streaming some or was that one
yeah i watched that yeah and at the end
of the second
part i stood up in the room that i was
in ovation
because you know what that dude yeah he
changed he changed everything for a lot
of people and those dudes were like
going
at like 10 uh all all in the middle of
the night yeah you know
that was i i loved their variety show
they had with the rat pack in vegas i
had no idea about it
they'd roll out that that card with
drinks yeah they'd be making drinks
they'd make drinks on the stage it'd be
like um oh that's cool dean martin
basically like going off on like stand
up and like the guys in the back like
sinatra and like sammy davis would be
like roasting him
like from the back and [ __ ] gentlemen
you know a full theater of people were
just like laughing at these guys
clowning around and everybody was
laughing nobody was like yeah
yeah you know that [ __ ] so there was
a comedian
he passed his name was jackie vernon
he's open for frank sinatra okay
so when you opened for frank sinatra or
you worked with frank sinatra
you were like on call 24 hours a day so
if frank said
three o'clock in the morning hey we're
gonna go get something to eat pally you
know you had to be downstairs
at three whenever they were leaving
right you were like
i'm 24-hour day gig so he says christmas
eve
[ __ ] three in the morning frank
sinatra goes hey
meet us downstairs we're gonna go eat
you know
and it's like all right so
he wants a grilled cheese sandwich at 3
30 in the morning in like the early 70s
and places weren't open 24 hours really
and they couldn't find a place and
they're like frank it's christmas eve
man you know there's a
[ __ ] i got to find a place that's open
they go to a chinese restaurant
and they said you got a grilled cheese
chinese people in there
and the fries and after they're sitting
all around a big table
and they go to the back and they
bring like bread like an open face
grilled cheese sandwich which you've
never seen so they bring them a plate
and it's like
bread with cheese bread with cheese open
face
and he everybody gets one he looks down
at it
goes this is what you call a grilled
cheese sandwich
he grabs a plate [ __ ] stands up and
throws it at the wall
of course both pieces of bread stick to
the wall
and then it's just silent in the
wrestling jacket goes
i picked up mine i [ __ ] threw it on
the wall mine's stuck
and everybody at the table got their
[ __ ] grilled cheese
open face and threw them at the wall so
there's literally like four 28 pieces of
cheese and bread hanging on the wall of
this chinese restaurant again
and takes out a big wad of money as guy
does and gives them like a grand and
they all leave and then
they were happy they should have kept
all those grilled cheeses up there yeah
yeah lacquer them tape them up there
yeah
that's what they did they just and when
that frank sinatra threw his
you're gonna throw that grilled cheese
open face yeah
i wouldn't think they have cheese at a
chinese restaurant no i don't cope with
cheese or like a standard like a
standard grilled cheese bread even right
right well i think you guys have a great
idea
it's so it's all about trying to be
early i'm digging them i think that and
you know what
there's no like you said there's there's
no
correlation or recognition for dudes
that just like consider i'm already
buzzed with that one beer yeah
there's another one over there like that
day i brought a couple edibles in here
and like
two 10 milligrams oh yeah gummy bears
and two beers yeah i brought my dog i
don't know how the [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah you're having a good idea
like you actually you actually didn't
bring your dog
oh what the [ __ ] was that dog yeah like
10 minutes into it you like gave me a
look you're like oh this is it
but this yeah this beer is doing yeah
where do you guys where are you going
you know i have a i have a couple of
restaurants one is the bruce hall in
torrance
okay oh i should do an event there we go
that'd be awesome man yeah
yeah tell us about how you like made
this though and like wanted to come up
with the idea with it
would you do a lot of the tasting yeah
yeah oh yeah yeah and then and that guy
was uh
so good man at uh uh brewing so so we
created the george lopez brewing company
yeah and there's four one is like a
hibiscus beer sour yes sour
it's great uh one of my favorites
the orange crema oh like you know that
50 50 bar that ice cream like the dream
sickle yeah yeah yeah
we have uh i did one that has a little
bit of orange and then challenge and the
other one's a
grapefruit ipa ipa yeah nice i'll be
good for the summer yeah yeah which is
i'm not i'm not a big ipa
but you could do that but even you know
when i
when i asked the guy that was brewing
and i said hey can you make a beer that
tastes like this is like yeah
you just said how you wanted it to taste
you know the you know guinness right
it's a dark
so i said there's there's this chocolate
that mexicans drink growing up like i
will eat that chocolate ground with the
chocolate right it's like a chocolate
disk and you put it in milk just boiling
it because so i said to that dude hey
can you make a beer that
tastes like i will eat the chocolate
that [ __ ] has it looks like
guinness but with no head you're nothing
and you're drinking and it tastes like
mexican hot chocolate
that sounds phenomenal and it's not
bitter it's beautiful
i think you guys would i think that's
really enjoyable
you know they sell goodness out of a can
yeah there's like instructions
it's like shake it up there's a ball in
here turn it upside down into a glass
yeah there's like a ball in there huh
yeah max and i had a couple of uh we got
a couple of guinnesses
um what was it when england played in
the final the world cup we went to that
bar uh
the old king's head tavern in santa
monica oh nice it was like beautiful
santa monica board yeah it's on the main
like
ocean avenue yeah yeah it was like being
in the uk right oh yeah it was packed
there's a 400 person line outside at 10
a.m we somehow
got in there's a guy in full um full
chainmail night skier
chainmail armor yeah and we had you know
probably eight guinnesses and
it was the most electric sporting event
i ever watched oh yeah
and was it like what time was it too
because uh the one experience like that
i had morning
yeah yeah it's open it's like seven
o'clock and the bar is packed and people
are
it was packaged back to the gills so the
match started at 12 pacific
eight in europe and it was packed
jam-packed at 9 45 on
and nobody would get it yeah yeah it's
it's so that i did that once
uh one other time in my life i worked on
the first season of ted lasso
and so they brought everyone to like a
yeah a bar for it was like a big
champions league game i forget what but
like
just the craziest atmosphere two stories
people going
crazy like climbing the raft
you know if we look at the day in a
24-hour
unit is looking is drinking at 7 am
frowned upon
in the whole 24 hours no there's a lot
of
definitely people like do you have
anything to do yeah yeah
i mean i like it to each his own i mean
you manage your own schedule
cereal sometimes at night for dinner why
can't i have a beer
when i left my day job to go and do
stand-up
1987 when we started to do clubs even
though nobody knew
knew us we drank during the day and then
went to go take a nap like we go play
golf
drinking at seven yeah done at 11. you
basically start working at nine o'clock
and then you go sleeping up from like 1
30 to like make sure
yeah and if you want a good
mid-afternoon nap you just have an early
beer or two yeah
all right guys well we got uh things to
do together we're gonna go to chicago
yeah yeah yeah
you just popped out of torrance a little
bit and popped out of torrance too yeah
that's easy all right right on uh what's
the people want to follow uh yeah do you
guys want to get just
talk about the instagram and the podcast
whatever you know if you've got [ __ ] to
plug plug away
yeah well yeah uh obviously you can find
us on instagram at friday.beers
uh that's where we're posting you know
seven days a week
all of our found footage sketches uh
we're really really psyched about this
new show we have
where can somebody get one of these bad
boys on friday beers dot shop
you can get all of our hearts on there
we'll have it on ours too yeah man
that's great um that's there and uh yeah
this podcast that
we just released the first episode of
last friday
it's like welcome welcome to friday
it's with atc it's a ton of great we'll
get you to do a voiceover
20 minutes of sketch comedy you tune in
on a friday where you're driving to work
you're leaving work you know what
nobody's doing that
yeah yeah just thank you guys for doing
that yeah yeah
quick hit of uh sketch comments somebody
said somebody texted me
uh a really good way to describe it i'm
gonna bring this up yeah
well while you're doing that i'll talk
about like and i'm a fan obviously
clearly like two [ __ ] awesome things
they do george if you haven't checked it
out or listeners whatever
um they do their almost friday posts
which are just these and you guys can
maybe describe it better but
they just it's impossible to like
encapsulate what the vibe of these are
but like they just find all the most
sort of like
awesome or unique or weird picture and
they just slap this like almost friday
thing on it
i'm doing a no-joke right yeah it's a
little tone setter
to your point it's hard to describe you
kind of just have to like all
they all
are you guys golfers yeah okay well
you're shitty but yeah we
even like just launched them going we
have a golf brand
here's what we're gonna do i'm gonna
take you guys out
to play golf at lakeside with the
godfather
luke wilson oh oh dude
stop come on you would be making dreams
coming yeah i want to do that
godfather i hit him up i said you around
he's a man in town
[Laughter]
he's an awesome dude man and we did a
movie together
henry poole and uh maybe 10 12 years ago
and we stayed
close man he's a great great guy cool
cool dude mellow just like that he's
mellow really
yeah right i mean those guys are like i
would make my year yeah yeah
this is always him because he always
trying to get out of [ __ ] hey luke don't
forget sunday matt ah
i'm not you know i could try i'm not
gonna be able to
[Music]
he's awesome so we'll go golf we'll have
some beers over there yeah i'll be
awesome
although he's one of those guys he
doesn't drink beer when he plays drinks
after but
i do so yeah i mean isn't that always
like the delicate art when you're
playing golf you're like
all right i can have like two or three
it's probably gonna honestly it probably
helps me play a little better
yeah there's marginally better than if
you go if you're
going and as soon as i start playing i
might as well have six [ __ ] i got
the weed cup or something i don't know i
have a party at my house who weed in the
pool
oh there's you guys will come to that um
oh the brownie cup brownie cup where you
like take it you play nine hole sober
and you play nine on the ninth tee
you drink a cranberry and vodka and then
you
split uh between four guys uh marijuana
brownie
and then from the tenth hole you count
every shot
and don cheadle won you know four years
ago with a [ __ ] nine on 18.
that
so it's myself we started at pebble
beach almost by accident
me don anthony anderson and and gh
who can smoke weed can't eat it so we
found his
family i gave him uh uh like two sleeves
of callaways
he put all six into this telephone pole
hard right
just six
um the golf brand called hit different
golf and we um
we play two on two where nine holes you
get through
you get the shaver stroke with for every
beer you drink
above a certain amount you know what
that might so we put a 12 pack in each
cart
and if you don't finish the 12 pack so
you have 10 of the 12
that means you get plus two on your
score but 14 out of 12 you get minus two
yeah so we play with the chakras deep
guys oh yeah we played we've probably
done no it's nine
it's nine so twelve uh twelve beers and
nine holes
twelve six nine hundred but you have
your partner so you had six oh okay
it's still a lot it's it's it's a lot
yeah
had to drink the most for nine holes i
mean you kind of go with your partner
you're like yo if you're playing better
maybe yeah you can so the beauty is you
can catch up if you drink more
yeah all right we're down four strokes
slam okay that's
why we call it terrible sorry i'll get
there's a certain amount of things like
where you have to like use
one guy's drive at least three times um
we played uh it's called the hit
different challenge so we played with
the chagos deep guys we played against
jt and strider
and podcasters yeah other podcasters
here and we were trying to find like
other
like and we don't have to play in it
like it would be hilarious if like
you know you and luke wanted to play
against like
tom cheadle and anthony anderson would
that be green
and then we have uh we have cameras
following too it's really good
yeah we kind of kept it anonymous until
[ __ ] i think we went on kimmel and
said yeah
i was like hey thanks and you know
putting all that [ __ ] out there but it's
a fun
i think that's a little more fun than
ours but it'll be and there's
also like little wrinkles during the uh
during the match so
the closest to the pin on a par three
gets to like make the other team shotgun
a beer and it doesn't count towards
their
actual collective score longest drive on
a par
five uh what is longest drive on a par
five uh
i forget if they have to like get one
off their score
i know that shortest if you if you never
if there's one where you
where you don't get past the ladies
tease that means you have to drink
one beer through a straw on that entire
hole
madison over there in the desert mike
melvin sings is private you want to see
anything
is it discovery cover mike was
discovering right we started at [ __ ]
we we finished in the dark yeah
we played before out there for [ __ ]
eight hours because at all those
state comfort stations oh yeah we would
eat then we would drink
and let people go by yeah go around and
on 18
we're in the state of the middle of
fairway the guy comes out with a cart
the lights are on he goes hey you guys
all right
we're like yeah we're all right and the
guy that was
leading hit it in the water and the
other guy made like a seven and
a half one shook hands in the dark
they've seen in hall pass the movie with
owen wilson and
uh they take the weed brownies and play
golf and one guy's like
doing a snowy
[Laughter]
like follow and subscribe to welcome to
friday yeah i just found the uh
the way to describe it a perfect little
20-minute joy booster
there you go that's all you need inject
it in shout out ricky millington
like shotgunning happiness yeah shotgun
had some happiness on a friday that's
right
so we got to what's your we got to
remember george's phrase
you'll feel better feel better longer
that sounds a little like a cialis
all right beautiful guys thank you guys
thanks for coming up
you